we got to catch this guy fast he's one
of the worst serial killers in history
Sherlock Wells I'm here to get your
killer let's hope we're not too late to
save his next victim red locks is dead
how I'm not sure I interviewed everyone
that was there and no one knows but I
did some digging okay so what are we
looking for here not looking listening
sound like the guy who just attacked us
sounds like an insect at us like a like
a cicada
whose cicada
hey everybody its charlie we got new
flash footage to break down the title of
the episode officially is the death of
vibe so everybody say a prayer for Cisco
but I think we all know what the writers
are winking at from behind the camera
there's a new round of that blast ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this so we'll start with the
death of vibe stuff so you see that open
hole in the ground with all of his vibe
gear crunched up he gets stabbed in the
back with that dagger the cicada has
been using think the whole idea is is
he's probably going to lose his powers
they foreshadow that heavily during
episode 2 because Cisco spent the entire
episode not being able to use his powers
because he was so emotionally attached
to like in a literal way their
vibes connected them across the
multiverse so he was just catatonic for
most of the first couple of episodes
because he couldn't deal with it
the cecile stuff was also a bit of
foreshadowing for that - like she's
losing her powers cicadas daggers sucked
away all Barry's powers and he had to
fight him just like a normal person
would so they're just getting you used
to the idea that part of the season will
be them dealing with that and learning
how to take him down without always
being able to use their powers like
that's what Sherlock wells is all about
at the end of the trailer
even though Sherlock Holmes seems like
he has super powers of deduction it's
just a totally normal person that's
incredibly intelligent so in the way
that they're doing a little bit of
Sherlock this season you can also see
why they're doing a lot of Barry CSI
work because all that goes hand in hand
with investigating crimes criminals the
things the team flash does but they used
to rely on their high tech satellite for
so that's why they destroyed the
satellite with a thinker just looking at
the other footage here obviously they
want to make you think like cicada is
gonna go after Joe he is still sitting
down in that frame remember the joke is
is that he's been sitting down in almost
every single scene that he's been in
since the first half of the season
maybe the actor hurt himself in real
life who knows but the whole idea here
is the probably going after someone that
he senses is a meta maybe that's why his
dagger is glowing maybe it acts as sort
of a divining rod for him he's supposed
to be this regular blue-collar guy so
it's not like he has a lot of huge
technology that helps him find other
metas the big thing here though is that
Joe doesn't have superpowers so why
would he want to
after Joe he's probably really there for
Cecile because she kind of has her
powers but because the title of the
episode is the death of vibe not the
death of Cecile it sounds like they just
want to make you think like they're
gonna go after her
you see Cisco's alarm go off they have
everybody LoJack with those panic
buttons especially the ones that don't
have superpowers in case some meta comes
after them so it might be one of those
situations where cicada initially comes
after Joe and Cecile Cisco and Barry
rushed to help then they wind up in the
fight out in the woods and that becomes
the big climax of the episode because it
does feel like a very Cisco centric
episode with the title like the death of
vibe iris has that line of dialogue
where she says worst killer in history
making it sound like cicada has been
around for much longer than we thought
the comic book version of cicada claims
that he got his powers when wall-e was
hit with the bolt of lightning he
appeared during the Wally West era not
during the Barry Allen era so because he
got his powers when Wally got hit with
the bolt of lightning he feels like it's
his destiny to steal his powers and use
them to resurrect his dead wife but on
the TV show cicada lost his daughter I
don't know if they're gonna be doing any
of that crazy resurrection stuff on the
TV show but what is the big lesson that
the flash has taught us about characters
losing people that they love is that
usually they just have to deal with it
like you can't go back and change things
because you create flashpoint Nora is
convinced that she can stop Barry from
disappearing during that future crisis
event that we keep seeing in the
newspaper but every single time
something like this happens usually the
person that was dead does not come back
and the people that are left alive have
to just learn to deal with it so if
you're confused why they're going so
full cicada this early in the season
usually they tease the villains out
longer the showrunner said that they're
actually gonna have three separate story
arcs this season usually what that
implies is that there are multiple
villains and there'll be another villain
in the next story arc then in the last
seven or eight episodes the real big
villain of the season will surface and
it'll be somebody a little bit different
so they just remains to be seen they've
got all this time-travel that's going on
with Nora she's gonna be around for most
of the season so I wouldn't be surprised
if some of those other story arcs deal
with stuff that's actually happening in
her timeline in the future like right
now they have this fight
Secada going on it would be really cool
to see how that affects what's going on
in the future so maybe we'll get a taste
for that soon they're teasing Caitlyn's
father in the next couple of episodes
maybe he or icicle winds up being the
villains of one of the next story arcs
but just keep that in mind multiple
story arcs so multiple villains big
theory time in my wildest fantasies
everybody wonders what's going on with
the reverse-flash
so that lightning shaped dagger absorbs
speed force energy in the comics
reverse-flash has a lightning-shaped
scepter wouldn't it be badass if
whatever new version of the
reverse-flash comes back steals that
lightning shaped dagger and uses it to
form his lightning scepter from the
comics the true purpose of the Lightning
shaped scepter is actually really
insidious - if you haven't read it in a
while
flash rebirth the original one from back
in 2009 when Barry Allen first came back
it shows up right at the beginning of
that you Bart Thawne reverse flash
breaks into Barry's lap at the Central
City Police Department kills the guards
with a lightning-shaped scepter then
using it is a lightning rod he recreates
the accident that gives Barry Allen
powers but the big twist is is that he
rearranged the chemicals just a little
bit differently and uses everything to
create the negative Speed Force so
that's sort of the beginning of the
negative Speed Force in the comics and
remember how Nora is wearing the Tachyon
enhancer and tachyons were really
important when the reverse-flash was
around during season 1 to make himself
faster and inside the flash museum she
stole reverse tachyons so it just sounds
like they're trying to wink at that from
the comics so just would be cool if they
try to tie all these Easter eggs
together but obviously no confirmation
they haven't said anything about how
they're gonna use the reverse flash this
season the way they've been teasing
these story arcs though I wouldn't be
surprised if they wait till a little bit
later in the season to tease reverse
flash out let me know in the comments
though who do you think is gonna be the
real big villain of the season if it's
not going to be cicada I've got some new
spider-man far from home footage to
break down that video we'll post in a
little while so no worries
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video new eg 12 please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here for my episode 2 video and click
here to learn when the Avengers 4
trailer is dropping in watch Tom
Hiddleston talk all about
the Loki character thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]